faire ça commence par francs mais ça
termine pas par six d'accord oui j'ai
compris je vous le citez les extraits
télé a vous de me dire autour de la
table s'ils appartiennent à francis
lalanne ou un autre franc ça commence
par seront à piéger un élève auto écoles
en se faisant passer pour le pire
moniteur de france est ce que ces mots
et françois l'embrouillé bravo qui a dit
ça c'est moi s'est lamenté là parce que
tiffany
bravo mademoiselle c'est pas possible ça
la regarde et je regardais mon orteil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m il est dehors il a mal il s'assoit par
terre
bref plein de crier ça va aller ça va
aller mieux
[Musique]
c'est moi pas fait autre chose
s'inquiète t'inquiète ça va le faire par
moi toi parle-moi de toi t'es marié non
en accenter douter belge ouais c'est
toujours la grève la guerre en ce moment
avec les français ont eu plein de
problèmes en belgique fera pas comme
excuse moi mais qu'est-ce que je rigole
[Applaudissements]
alors ça commence par franck est
l'événement sportif
notre ancien président jacques chirac à
ces genres de connaître il a fait genre
dans un événement sportif de connaître
les joueurs de l'équipe de france alors
que pas du tout 198 france 90 euros
francis tjrs était un passionné de foot
et c'était bien sûr jacques chirac
france 90 c'est génial ça n'ont pas le
droit d'y pénétrer
sinon il serait exclu la prochaine coupe
du monde dix ans et alors ils ont
déployé les sécheurs je l'aimé je les
verrais bien déployer des sacs de
couchage et puis se coucher dans le rond
central pour dormir
le précédent vers les publics vous avez
eu des images parce qu'on l'avait on les
avait jamais à bessat là je peux les
voir mille fois ça commence par feront
ce vénère en disant qu'on lui coupe la
parole alors que pas du tout ça marche
francis était sur le plateau de c'est à
vous en 2015 tu demandais anne-elisabeth
lemoine de te laisser parler alors que
le plateau était complètement silencieux
je regrette presque de ne pas l'avoir
écrit qu'à une semaine parce que ça
m'aurait permis de poser la vraie
question que pose tout s'est tu
vous allez me laisser parler un petit
peu
[Applaudissements]
elle allait parler et ça faisait un
moment déjà qu'il n'arrêtait pas de me
couper et ça c'est un des pires
souvenirs de ma vie en fait j'avais été
diffamé à cause de da coeur du front
national avait raconté des mensonges et
qui avait été repris par toute la presse
comme si c'était la vérité c'est elle a
été diffusée dans la presse est bon non
sur tous les réseaux sociaux et quand je
suis arrivé sur le plateau en fait ils
ont ils m'ont remis en accusation avec
des mensonges et franchement c'est un
des pires souvenirs de télévision que
j'ai eu
voilà ça commence par francs une chaîne
dont l'un a vu un journaliste péter un
câble parce qu'il a raté son lancement
aux infos le journaliste gilles
bernstein ce veilleur nous face à julien
benedetto parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
faire son lancement regarder finalement
à droite on se réjouit de ce ralliement
puisqu'à force de marteler que emmanuel
macron c'est françois le ronde et bien
ça leur permet de de continuer au plus
tard
[Applaudissements]
je suis fan de sega ça commence par
francs une chaîne a montré sur videmment
se ramasser à cause d'un hamac
c'est un problème très moderne qui n'a
rien de traditionnel mais qui a la
particularité de pouvoir se déplacer
facilement les pieds sont se déplie les
pieds se déplie très facilement et vous
pouvez l'installer dans votre jardin et
surtout il à l'emplacement pour m la
lecture est pour m la boisson donc c'est
vraiment le sophie ramener chez nous
justement c'est pas la bonne
on s'est installé
[Applaudissements]